skating is extreme i i can't do anything
extreme you know the we got to protect
i'm like a porcelain vaz
you know i'm no good in pieces
what's up gq i'm maddie matheson and
here's some of my essentials
[Music]
so
you know this is a vintage motorcycle
helmet it's a buco
you know it's incredible it's protection
through research really this is just a
really great helmet for riding um
it's you know it's one of those things
you know you're riding vintage you know
choppers or whatever you're riding and
and you get started buying old helmets
look watch you put it on like this you
put a helmet on like this
and that's as good as it can get
this is one of my essentials if you ride
motorcycles get yourself a helmet
where did you get that opening this one
i i bought off of some random guy on the
internet it's perfect maybe it's filled
with head lice maybe it's filled with
sawdust i don't know is it really even
safe i don't know it looks cool kinda
here we go sunglasses so i'm 40 years
old now i was born in 1982 my eyeballs
are rotten
the iphone has melted them
i believe maybe it's my age maybe it's
me just looking you know screen time 65
hours a day but i had a friend who's a
little bit older than me said hey check
this out and he gave me his readers and
i put them on i was like what
this is so great i can see
you know
and uh
now i can look at my phone for endless
amount of time and see what's actually
going on when life gets crazy as i'm
older now the sun kind of hurts my eyes
while i drive and i drive quite a fair
amount so when i'm driving i like to
wear sunglasses
and uh these sunglasses these are i
believe the j the j silhouette or the
model oliver's peoples i found these a
couple years ago
bought my first i've had like four four
or five pairs of these
i keep buying them all over people now
that this is on [ __ ] gq can you send
me some okay a lot of people are always
asking about this [ __ ] these sunglasses
are cool
and period and send me some i've bought
four or five pairs of these okay
[Music]
wow
big moment here for everybody one of my
essentials is just the stainless steel
yeti kind of thermos cup i put coffee in
it
every morning i go out and walk around
the farm and go look at vegetables and
take in the day kind of set my pace a
little meditation
you know well not really while you're
drinking caffeine meditating you know
just like the fake meditating that
everybody does
once again as a bigger dude there's not
a lot of options to buy like certain
types of clothes so i've fallen in love
with hats this is not a vintage hat this
is a new hat this is my clothing company
rosa vagosa it's not even out yet you
don't even know about it it doesn't
really matter maybe this is this is a
spoiler alert don't really care but this
hat is an incredible silhouette of uh my
favorite kind of trucker hats this is a
hat underneath it i don't know why i
just this is
a bit much i'd say i also love
you know coming across good bucket hats
is uh a real joy and this is a abc wide
world of sports
vintage it's kind of disgusting on the
inside you know something like your
grandfather would have in a photo
sitting on the beach in palermo and so i
like wearing it it's cool
look
now i'm cool you're cool too
you probably have great essential bucket
hats i just happen to have the wide
world sports abc one uh so mine's just a
little bit cooler than yours and a
little more essential
this is a rolex it's very old
i think it's from the 40s it was given
to me as a gift from [ __ ]
uh
he owns maker pizza
and um
he gifted me this
he asked if i wanted to watch i never
wore a watch i'm not a watch person
and i made a couple jokes about a rolex
i was just like you know i
i think i want a rolex and then he's
like why do you want a rolex like you
don't wear watches why do you want to
roll it i'm like i don't know i'm like
an adult now i'm like i would never buy
it i don't know
all my friends like have rolex this is
like this thing you know but the thing
about it is he's very he's thoughtful
because i didn't want some like new
showy
whatever the kind of role i don't even
know what they are i just think it's
actually genuinely cool and i think if i
was to wear a watch if i was to wear a
watch i'd wear this one which makes it
essential so here's the one watch i
would wear so this is just a
point-and-shoot film camera
um kyra sierra t zoom got the carl zeiss
lindsay
you know i think a lot of people
probably got the contacts 2000 or
uh the yashica
um you know
t zoom 4 or some [ __ ] but
i asked trish to get me a good film
camera for christmas
uh forever ago
and uh this has been my camera that i i
travel with and just take film photos
and um
yeah
you know
capture the moment so
okay
as a chef as a home cook
as a father as a partner as a husband as
a friend
this is truly
one of the greatest cast iron pans i
love this this is a matheson
cookware cast iron pan this is
amazing heavy duty we got the knurled
handle two hands throw this in a fire
put it into an oven hit somebody in the
head
don't do that though
um but this thing is like really
um something i'm really proud of we
designed it with cast or shout out to
castor
we love them
this is a 10 inch cast iron pan
and we developed it with the extra kind
of lip up here so when you're cooking
you can throw your steaks or something
in there and then when you're cooking
you hold it back here with the long
handle and then you can spoon and baste
and with the
like the wider edge here you can kind of
pool your butter or your fat and kind of
baste
which i love and then when you add
there's a little dot here on the bottom
that will help you in a dot a small
little dot here
that will help you align
the pan and then you got the lid on
there this is definitely an essential
thing in my life
and uh
you know just something i'm really proud
of i love it
here we go
everybody needs a good tote a good
duffel bag
this is the one that i obviously
actually travel with all the time it's
got the ykk zipper which you you know
very utilitarian you got that it can zip
up keep your privacy privacy'd uh put
your little you know you got some
lingerie in there put it you know that
little zip zip is gonna make you keep
your sexy things nice and safe i i still
just have like stuff in here i got a
pair of socks i got a belt got another
bucket i'm always traveling with just
like the key things a good bad brain
shirt look at that when was the last
time you saw an look at this this is
like a crop this is the weirdest cut
shirt in the history you know quickness
great album people don't really love it
but it's a good album
um
but there you go you need a tote a daily
driver this is my daily driver i go
anywhere i go this kind of bag goes with
me
and um
i really love it i check it all the time
so it's just like getting thrown around
on conveyor belts and all that [ __ ] like
i check it i don't like to carry
anything in the airport i don't bring a
carry-on ever i'm like the opposite of
most people want to do carry-ons
i don't like walking through the airport
with anything you know i checked the bag
i don't mind wait 15 minutes for bags
wait 15 minutes for bags
okay so this
is kind of
you know an amazing thing we took some
vintage dead stock
car hearts
and nick at shout out to nick and small
talk
he does uh hand-painted pants and denims
and all this stuff
and uh i put a bunch of like my favorite
music on here i got the blues mobile the
bluesmobile was such a big thing when we
were kids
shout out to the blues brothers in
chicago
we got the blues brothers mobile when we
were growing up my dad literally bought
an old cop car uh from like an auction
and we literally grew up driving around
in some beat up [ __ ] box cop car with
like like the old plymouth with the
white door and the blue it was like
incredible
sure nick is probably pretty busy
making a lot of stuff right now but
he makes amazing things so you know send
him a pair of pants if you can get him
to draw things that you love on your
pants and wear them you know
essential shoes for me even though my
chiropractor says i need to start
wearing actual shoes that gave me
support
but for some reason
i wear these shoes every single day i've
been wearing you know
these van slip-ons for a long
long long time like grade seven or eight
i finally got my first pair i always had
like a pair like you know i had like air
walks at a pair of air walks or like
you know big chunky pair like america's
or like
like some skate shoe or simple i can't
skate too much you know i fall snapped
my wrist hurt my elbow
i don't do anything extreme i'm like a
[ __ ] porcelain voss
you know i'm no good in pieces
so i'm not like i don't know if you know
this about me
i'm not really a uh
a deodorant person or like self-care
with the skin i don't have the routine
or i get it for a long long time
and and then i started having kids and i
don't know just in my older age i was
like i need to start doing maybe
something and moisturizing i you know
get a couple dry spots
[Music]
i take one here i go one there and then
and then i do one here and one here and
then
i feel like i saw a meme where somebody
like somebody just took like thing and
how dudes like do their face i'm doing
the dude thing and then i just do this
and then i do this and then i come
and i rub it all over my face my
eyeballs
and and you know now
carpe diem anything that's coming at me
guess what
we're lubed up we're ready to go we're
ready to rock i'm moisturized come at me
we're all good or bad i got juicy little
baby skin now thanks gq for letting me
show you some of my essentials it was a
fantastic time
make sure
that uh you know you take care of the
things that you love